[Music]
got through the city coming in hot
what's up fam a little bit after nine
here a little bit of a late start
it's not because of the teams because of
me and my issue with the pursuit of 1
000 horsepower on my truck because I got
problems I can't leave stuff alone
you know those TRX trucks that Hellcat
engine it's just uh
it's just like you you get this this
mold this clay and you can't just leave
it alone there's too much potential with
it
so I was at addiction Motorsports uh
doing some Corsa uh
uh Extreme Exhaust today
uh uh I in installed the the air intake
myself from jmb
so uh we got some plans for this thing
and uh we got some exciting content
around the truck the tuning other
people's cars uh I'll keep you posted on
that but uh yeah obsessed with that
right now gotta reach that thousand
horsepower Milestone it's not that it's
not anything a lot of people haven't
done I want to turn into a demon because
Ram doesn't offer that option on the TRX
I don't know why they do it on the uh
The Challengers but it has so much
potential to and get to get to the demon
to get to a thousand everywhere it comes
with 700 and
5 horsepower so you're only talking
about 295 here it's not
out of this world dude we can get there
and I have the team to do it uh we'll
have some news on that once we once we
figure out details we have some fun
stuff coming up regards to that
um yeah man so that's what that's what
made me a little late I don't know if
you know this but a lot of
um
people in the business of tuning Cars
and auto shops they're not exactly
um what would you say they're not
exactly punctual when it comes they go
at their pace and I um you know I I took
that uh for granted and thought I could
do a few things and still be here by
nine and you're an idiot Brendan and you
know you I'm at the mercy of their
schedule all good baby all good TRX
demons and black Buffalo nicotine that's
what we do
I'm different now man I'm Different
you're different trucks too
by the way dudes dudes yeah I like my
Bros what do you think yeah friendships
cheer [__] dude but I remember like uh
when I did why do you worked in my car
when I did the import car stuff they
would say like it'll be done in like a
month
you go there two months three months
four months five months it's never done
if it's a big project it's a you know it
is it's just the nature of the beach yes
sir yeah they're busy it's literally and
you know they have a lot going on so
it's not like they're like I was like
man I really I get to be at the street
at nine right now what not happening we
don't give a hell okay
you okay in this that uh addiction Eddie
had addiction and this is I think this
is why I'm gravitating towards
especially like the truck Community
they're so dope like so many people like
I don't like to post my car stuff like
that when Kim TRX I know there's a lot
of people would you know Raptors and
trx's and then I posted just the amount
of like just dope people that I met I
was like oh this is so cool it's like
people like oh man I did this be careful
of this use this like addiction here in
Semi Valley which isn't far from here
for me Eddie when I reached out as a kid
I'm gonna do some work I want to get to
you know a thousand horsepower that's
how I all my contacts came through dope
people online it's like Eddie's the best
in the biz I've worked with them don't
go here do this be wary of this oh use
this guy is it's it's just like this
world where I'm like oh this is dope
yeah and then once I you know I'm like a
dog with a bone once I get on something
I'm like oh I can get a thousand
horsepower turn a demon TRX
say less and then I become obsessed with
it and I watch YouTube videos people
send me dope you know breakdowns of
their trucks I'm like oh this is Off to
the Races and then it's all I think
about it's literally all I'll think
about I get anxiety until I check that
box it's a problem it's a dope Community
though man so shout out to you guys I'll
be for you people and onto cars and
trucks my bad what can I do but uh yeah
man so shout out to everybody in that
Community man uh we should meet up I'm
just gonna throw that out there we
should meet up make it a regular thing
once a month and just you know get to
know each other outside of uh social
media in forums that's what we should do
man create a real Community all right
um but let's move on to the fights
that's why most of you are here
um you got the uh
you had the the Mexican Independence
card
um the Mexicans went ham huh they do
Mexicans did their thing started uh I
started tuning in with Tracy Cortez
that's my girl love Tracy she's a beast
coming off a layoff she's undefeated in
the UFC in the flyweight Division and
she got done I did 30 27 might be a
little biased uh she's a homie but um I
had a 30-27 she looked phenomenal lost
her sister like a lot went into that man
you know so you could tell how emotional
she was but uh she looked she looked
great man undefeated dude undefeating
the flyweight division she's gonna get a
big fight next
who was the young lady
oh it was that that Loop uh yeah
dude
she went straight up MTV's yeah bully
breakdown I mean beat the crap I haven't
seen somebody get domain like that that
Elise read you could tell her team was
like oh my Throne the towel dude live to
fight another day they look like it
looked like amateur compared to Elite
world-class level I I'm seeing a beat
down like that someone would go in there
and get like clipped or whatever and
that's not really a beat down uh this
was bad this is she had two horns
hanging off her head you could tell
she's like damn that's not snowflake no
no you thought you fought I think she's
Mexican
trust me she's Mexican she's Mexican as
hell next in Canadian oh fine out of
Canada
boy she beat the crap out of that girl
she has some good wins too just some
good wins she's gonna be a prom God dang
she beat that girl's ass that was a
Savage Savage performance
um
and then our boy uh Rosa Junior
he decided to take all the embarrassment
of his last fight where he looked you
know pretty bad but he's also 18. and uh
he took it out on our boy Terence
Mitchell that overhand left it's like a
hook straight left dish they were thrown
from the get-go
um and then you got to the coming event
I was most I'll be straight up on us I
was most excited for JDM versus Kevin
Holland I thought this would be such a
fun fight
not the not fireworks not fireworks
um I thought Kevin Hall was gonna give
JDM a lot more issues especially I think
he had a six or eight inch reach
advantage and usually they the UFC does
a good job bringing this up anytime it's
like over like two or four inches reach
Advantage they have like a crazy success
rate it's like a 65 or more success rate
of winning if they have that big of a
reach Advantage Kevin Holland I think
that six to eight inch reach events so
he should have been able to have more
success
um
you know JDM is the real deal we've been
saying this for a while
um and obviously Kevin Hollins no punk
it just uh maybe an off night in the
office
you know and even off night in the
office he lost in a split decision like
JDM that's how talented this kid is
the word around the water cooler is you
know he has his own his own gym now he's
on his camp now to quote him I think he
goes I'm calling the shots now that's
usually a red flag
some guys figure it out there's been
world champions who have done the same
things and figure out in general though
if the fighters calm the shots it's
usually not a good thing no I'm not
saying that's a Kevin Hall's situation
some to be wary about let's see how his
next fight goes you call that Neil magni
you know usually you want someone to
oversee things uh in your Camp because
the days have just shown up and not
having a game plan and just going out
there like I'm just gonna react it's
just you know that's
eight years ago you know five years ago
maybe you know but now you're talking
about legit get you need a legit game
plan you need execution you need a
proper Camp you have to be professional
you have to be very GSP about it he's
the one that brought this blueprint over
guys are implementing that for for a guy
like Kevin Holland who's so talented you
can't be The Driver of your own team now
you want to definitely have some say and
obviously Kevin Han's a smart dude and
has all the skill in the world but you
need that that that coach it seem like
hey man for for JDM you have such an
advantage like let's work on more
takedowns let's work on uh getting to
the back we can't just get in a sparring
match because jdm's gonna have the
advantage there JDM just want to keep
the the fight staying the entire time
that's what he did because Kevin Holland
allowed him to Kevin Holland went for a
takedown a little early on went for like
this weird kind of body lock didn't have
success and then just negated that game
plan just did his thing
so I I think the days are just showing
up biting down your mouthpiece I'm like
we'll figure it out when especially in
the maybe outside of the top 15 you can
do that once you start getting the top
15 it's maybe and I don't even agree
with that but I'm just saying that Kevin
Holland's so talented he's gonna be able
to get away with it for a long time
until you start getting these big dogs
who have a game plan who went through a
camp who have a game plan they stick to
it no matter what they execute it those
guys are tough to beat man they're tough
to beat so uh I'm a Kevin Holland fan
man he's a fun he's a fun one you can
tell he's a personality he's a fan
favorite great personality he has his
own podcast I think he's still doing it
yeah check him out Kevin Holland's pod
but he's a beast you just you just hope
and I'm not saying this but you just
hope that he has somebody in his ear
who's like Kate if we fight Neil magni
let's focus on this Neil struggles with
Jiu Jitsu on the ground let's just not
make it a sparring stand-up match you
know because you do got to expose these
guys weaknesses as you get to the upper
echelon dudes you got to find out
because if you're going to tip for Tat
and they're just a little bit better on
the feet you're gonna have some issues
you know and you're gonna lose decisions
because most guys if they just went in
and went oh I'm just gonna figure it out
usually get knocked out or finished by
JDM you know but Kevin Owens so damn
talented so good elusive athletic uh and
wild too that's what you can't really
count you know when you fight him so
um yeah you just hope he has a little
bit of guidance that's my only worry
with that because you know obviously the
homdat thing happened
um I'm not gonna knock him for that the
Wonder Boy Thompson
you know
if you understand yeah you understand
and then he end up shooting
um you know again if you're his coach
and listen he's a black belt dude he's a
black belt travel to Black Belt that's a
huge advantage over a guy like one boy
Thompson
because you're not you're not gonna out
strike a guy like that
secondary black belt yes no pump wait no
secret black belt in kung fu yeah
as they get of course yeah yeah he's
Savage you have a black belt from crafts
looter you do you know you're Jujutsu
yeah you know you're BJJ whereas the
kids say you know you're Jets I hate
when people call it Jets
hey Jets I don't like gifs I don't like
the word cap
I'm getting older yeah
um but yeah that's all it is Kevin Han
he just needs some I I assume that's why
he needs to get over the hump because
you know he's a top five Talent he's
there but you can't just wing it you
can't at this level in the UFC in 223
can't go and then hopefully figure it
out you gotta have some sort of game
plan you just have to uh for JDM you
know another big win man it was good for
him because he's coming off that he
thought a monster but it's on short
notice nobody knew who the guy was so
everyone was the hype on JDM kind of
came down a little bit but yeah the dude
is a Savage why they didn't put him on
the Australian card with Izzy so weird
yeah hey man we know you're we're
fighting your backyard but can you fly
12 000 miles to Vegas and fight the Apex
Center on Maxi Independence Day
um find a Mexican no no no no no you're
fine a black dude from Texas
oh that makes sense on the Mexican card
you know
but there you go dude's undefeated
undefeated in the UFC
he's giving me a prom man and also he he
didn't take too much damage he looked
good
um he should get a big dog next after
you beat Kevin Holland
and then here's where the controversy
comes I don't think there's too much the
controversy comes from the terrible
judging which we always run into Alexa
Grosso and Valentina shevchenko
so we're texting last night chin yes we
were because I'd I'd stand up Saturday
night in Pasadena so I missed the main
event and then I had to race home
because my CU Buffs were playing CSU
um
I knew that you got to remember for
those people I'm not going to see you
because they didn't destroy CSU that's a
rivalry game so it's always a little
different it's only the rivalry games
are always you can blow them out damn
you're wrong we've definitely blown them
out before but it's just it's it's a
different vibe what I the positives are
we know cu's not like they were the past
10 years where they're just soft and not
tough and no fight in them I like that
they went into overtime and were able to
pull it out and that their offense
wasn't clicking and that their defense
played crappy in the first half and they
were still able to pull out a win
against a rivalry you know that's big
and I think that's going to pay
dividends as they get going now Travis
Hunter has a last-rated liver which I've
had I was out the entire season but
maybe I'm just a
vajayjay about it my you know the
doctors wouldn't let me play football my
senior in high school after I got hit in
the ribs and Travis Hunter the guy took
a cheap shot on him and has the last
rated liver they say he's out three to
four weeks which can't be that bad but
here's the problem you have the possibly
the best player in the nation now we're
at Oregon next week top three toughest
places to play in the nation so that's
gonna be a tough one especially coming
off the CSU people are I think it's good
I think all the pressure's not on
because after CSU they're like maybe
they're not that good
we know they're better than light years
better than the last few seasons light
years better so kudos to Dion they're
the most talked about team in college
football
The Rock shows up you got little Wayne
there you got Offset you have all these
celebrities which is annoying but
whatever I get it
but I think the CSU what it did is made
him not as I think people like oh
they're not great yet no did we won one
game last year everybody needs to chill
so I think now the expectations made a
little lower now they go to Oregon they
beat Oregon without possibly the best
player in the nation in Travis Hunter
they beat Oregon
the amount of hype that's gonna happen
before they play SC at home and SC is
the best team in the Pack 12 Bar None
and they have the four they have the
hydrogen winner from last year uh Caleb
the amount of hype and Views that things
in git is going to be mind-blowing might
be the most watched college football
game of all time it's gonna be insane CU
is already setting records already
setting records for most watched games
it's nuts their tickets are more
expensive than Denver Broncos
Colorado all we have right now we have
CU football and we have Denver Nugget
basketball everything else sucks wiener
our Broncos are awful they're same team
that they were last year just with a
better Coach cool Russell Wilson's not
the answer and we have no other tools we
just find a way to lose and then uh
obviously the Rockies are besides
Oakland A's the worst team you've ever
seen
were the were the Indians from uh that
movie what was the movie
another in the Indians great movies oh
come on with uh Bad News Bears know
right
I don't know dude hit the showers
no come on with uh Charlie sheena's the
wild thing is the pitcher oh damn it I
know that
oh how's it called
I don't know we should guess it yeah we
should guess it and it has the it has
the baseball with the mohawk on it for
the cover Charlie Sheen
jabu
yeah I know that movie too
damn it Google it come on you want to
guess it or Google it no I just guess it
Wild Thing wow thing
Major League
that's a stupid name
it's so simple it doesn't make a major
league like Majors all right I have that
Jersey
not the Wild Thing Jersey I should have
worn it today dude
it's all weird when you're in the Old
School Cleveland Indians Jersey I only
have nothing to do with it I just like
the logo
I don't know how he got got there but um
back to the main event that's
controversial so I was uh
the reason I had to watch this entire
card on delay was because my CU Buffs uh
were busy staying undefeated
without the best player in the nation
not a big deal
um but we'll find out the point is we'll
find out next week against Oregon how
good they are we'll find out that's the
real deal at Oregon's a tough game but
um
so I watched the the Alexa grazo and
chefchenko fight uh obviously I knew
just from social media and Friends
texting me uh that it went to a draw I'm
I'm not mad I know I'm in the minority
here I'm not mad at drawls at all draws
if it's sometimes it's better than
somebody getting screwed
um the way that the issue with this is
the way that they calculate it to get to
a draw that that judge I gave it a 10-8
should never work again should never
work again now to their credit judges uh
are supposed to be more lenient on
giving 10 8. the UFC wants more 10-8s
the the commission wants you to give out
more tenants if that's a tenant round to
that dude then chefchenko should add
10-8 rounds earlier
yeah it was it was not if that's his
judging criteria well if that's a 10-8
we're getting take it down rear naked
choke almost finish the fight well
chefchenko did the same thing to Grosso
in in what in the third round so the the
judging there's a little all over I
don't have I don't have an issue with
the draw this how I scored it
I had uh I think uh let me think if I
remember right but I had it two
two four and five for Grasso two four
and five
two four and five for Grasso pretty
clear I thought pretty clear I I think
it's tough to give chefchenko three to
find chefchenko three rounds
that's where I'm at on it I I I had it
2-2 going into the fifth yeah I was like
oh it's two this pretty clear as day two
two I think most
experts quote unquote in the this
fighting field The Real Housewives of
UFC had it 2-2 going to the fifth so my
question would be shouldn't be
controversial
who do you give the fifth round to not a
lot of action then a minute 30 left
chefchenko throws his stupid spinning
kick gets taken down
and then Grasso has her back almost
submit sir
finishes around on her back okay let's
cross those round you had two two going
to the fifth once Grasso's fight
so even though it's a draw Grasso still
stays the champion yeah the my favorite
part of the whole night card wasn't
great but though my favorite part of the
whole night all night I think it's a
language barrier issue Grosso they put
the belt on she's like yeah and DC who I
absolutely loved he sees like uh so how
do you feel you know you retained the
Bell but you know it was a draw and you
know did you feel good and you know
what's it feel like to find uh Mexican
Independence Day and she's like I feel
good I I won the fight I won the fight
he's like you didn't it was a drawl but
uh how you feeling about it I think
she's because you know they put the belt
around her you know Shawn shell because
Dana was there he put that she was like
oh I won yeah and she was like I won
he's like well no it was a draw but yeah
you retain your belt so I think she got
to the back and like no you didn't win
it was a draw I don't want to see a
rematch
uh first fight obviously Grasso chokes
her out second fight draw she didn't
beat her I'm good
I'm good
yeah in uh blanchfield deserves the
night shot and that's gonna be a tough
fight for Grasso blanchfield is she's
young we need new blood in that division
let's get it rolling Chef Chango had her
shot twice didn't achieve a win
we know how that goes all set all good I
thought Grasso also won that fight we're
good I don't need a third I don't I'm
not a huge fan of of rematches unless
it's an epic fight unless it's just
something epic
um you know uh Gus's Finn Jon Jones uh a
fight like that you know Something Real
historic then I'm in then I'm in you
know uh Johann Jung check and uh Whaley
that great fight running back yeah if
it's an epic fight it's like back and
forth like oh man they just you know
throwing blows and I could give this
round to her that all right let's run
that back but when it's like this I'm
good this wasn't an epic fight I thought
Grosso won just the judges sucked all
right
I'm all set let the let the Young Buck
in blanchfield take her stab at it now
she's gonna be a problem she's young and
we need that new it's good to get new
blood in there chefchenko in fighting
years is 97 years old you know she
looked good though yeah they both look
great so good I thought uh Grasso you
know especially when she dropped there
and she just hits harder when she hits
you could tell just chefchenko felt
every bit of that so
shot the Grasso she's the champ don't
need a rematch it's Claire's day Blanche
field is the next in line just do it now
just announce it now
yeah that's a tough list there ooh and
chin has a crush on Alexa Grasso
[Music]
has a crushed on it during the text I
was like man that's aggressive we're
just and then finally you're like she's
cute dude I was like oh I see what's
going on yeah yeah she's a cutie yeah
and about us she is about us dude zero
emotion when she gets hit between rounds
she's just stand there just
yeah dude she's a stone face she was
yeah
super impressive and the uh Latinas have
had a tough time lately they've been
losing all their belts our boy Brad
Moreno lost his belt yeah Rodriguez
Alexa Grouse was the last Mexicano to
hold that gold strap she almost lost it
that what do they do with that judge you
think Jim
I would love for them
no to be put on like a like a like a
post-fight press conference on a pound
just to interview him like what what
were you thinking uh it would say Mike
Something Mike Bell Mike Bell quick
question for Mike
trying to be cool here not freak out
how'd you get to 10 8 and then let him
explain himself and maybe to open
people's eyes why they don't do that I
don't know
I like Don recruits like well we're
heading in the right direction at least
we're showing his name so he can get
harassed all night I guess you know
because they have to take some sort of
accountability I I just want to how did
you get to 10-8 and it and then let's
say he breaks it down he's like guess
what how I get to an eight close to
finishing her I'm like okay and they
asked her to score more 10-8s you know
more favorably so that's what I'm trying
to do okay good argument then how did
you not give
earlier rounds chefchenko 10A yeah very
similar take down got her back got her
neck
very similar so how how would you give
the fifth 10A but not say
um you know the the Third
that would be my question to him
explain uh cool you're you're Mr 10A
then just explain to me how you don't
have a 10-8 earlier in the fight yeah
that'd be my only question
and then I would fire him yeah
I'd fire him
yeah I don't know man but he's probably
all like oh that's Mexican Independence
dude let's not mess this thing up I
think there was earlier I'm headed to
Fiesta after this you know yeah but I'm
trying to get some bad scoring earlier
on too with other cards I forgot that
was of course of course
yeah but that's yeah 10-8 come on
this is Mike Bell white judge
okay
well uh entertaining card though
entertaining card
um let's see here
oh so I thought this was pretty crazy so
at for UFC 295 with Jon Jones versus CPA
miocic the the most expensive ticket to
be there is 112 000 the least expensive
is 700 and 12 dollars
yeah
that is insane
it's New York Jon Jones heavyweight
title who can afford 700 tickets for the
least expensive for the nosebleeds at my
Square Garden might as well watch it at
home yeah
good for them though
I guess you'll make more money
uh so Eric nixic was on uh Ariel's show
and he said that uh Strickland was
almost pulled from the fight because he
had like an altercation with some fan
and he punched him in the stomach and
the Australian authorities actually were
about to like
cancel him wouldn't that been a shame
dude how crazy was your title fight it's
very Strickland but we didn't if this
didn't happen we didn't know he would
have won like oh Sean Strickland just
self-sabotage me you know yeah yeah
but yeah so they even said oh so Nixon
said that they even were about to fly
out John Crouch because Jerry cannonier
was the backup fighter oh my God that's
how close it got yeah wow Dana White uh
backsplants for walks back plans for on
a Sunday rematch yeah no so all he said
basically was like people were like
misquoting him because he you know when
they first asked him if you know if it
should be a rematch he's like yeah maybe
but then the headlines are saying like
yeah that's the next match I mean to use
his own words because I never make
fights after yeah fights it's just not
what I do he's done it a ton of times
which is all good
I don't think we're twisting his words
he was like yeah you know does that make
sense no he didn't say we're definitely
doing it you know no he didn't no they
definitely twisted his words
yeah yeah that's how it goes that's the
media
that's how it goes by the way
DraftKings
that is how it goes this and this is how
it goes if you want to watch football
make bank if you want to bet on my CB
Buffs that organ I think they're 18 and
a half Point dogs you know I'm riding
with my Goldie buffaloes man you have
the NFL season popping uh don't discount
the Cincinnati Bengals they're all into
it that's what they do slow starters Mr
Joe Burrow's gonna get it right man the
Tiger The Tiger King right we're back
with another week of football and
draftking Sportsbook is keeping you in
the NFL action with great offers every
single game you got Thursday Night
Football yeah Saturday college football
you got Sunday football Monday Night
Football it's all good baby watch your
favorite teams or the teams you hate bet
against them with my friends at
DraftKings new customers can bet five
dollars and get 200 instantly in bonus
bets throw five down on any of this
week's epic matchups to walk away an
instant winner the Dolphins are rolling
baby them fins is rolling and DraftKings
isn't stopping there all customers can
take advantage of two new offers every
game day this September football's more
fun when you're in on the action so
download the app right now sign up with
the coach shop show new customers can
bet five dollars to get 200 instantly in
bonus bets only on draftking Sportsbook
an official Sportsman partner of the NFL
with a coach shop show the crown is
yours to make your picks don't listen to
me especially on five picks don't listen
to me I'm biased as hell football I'm
also biased see you all day
use fancy Guru go to fancy Guru when you
use fancy Guru and you you can make my
own DraftKings but let these experts
help you out that's why I reached out to
them because I'm like Drake I'm bad at
picking I curse people let fancy Guru
the expert so actual experts that give
picks on UFC NFL MLB college football
they do it all there it's literally
their jobs they're expert Pickers
they're going to help you make Bank bro
use fancy Guru all right but use
DraftKings when you want to make money
and the crown is yours so DraftKings
promo code shop show I gotta read all
that now Tim you got stuff this is the
only downside of going live
Gambler or visit www dot
1 800 gambler.net in New York call 8778
Hope NY or text Hope NY 467 369 and
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call
888-789-7777 or visit
ccpg.org please play responsibly on
behalf of Bhutto Casino and Resort KS
licensees partner Golden Nugget Lake
Charles la
21 plus age varies by jurisdiction void
in Ontario sea
sportsbook.draftkings.com football terms
for eligibility terms and responsible
gamble responsible gaming resources
bonus bets expire seven days after
issuance eligibility and deposit
restrictions apply yeah all right yeah
do that from now on I don't want to
anymore yeah it's the worst it is the
worst yeah
but we love them DraftKings yeah we do
love DraftKings you love fantasy Guru
shout out to all them I'll tell you what
man you're probably like man this guy
gets a pep in this step dude and one
thing I love is sheath underwear oh my
God they are the very best she's
underwear makes the most comfortable
briefs I've ever worn every time you
hear my voice or if you're able to see
this fat face it would be obvious that
I'm wearing a pair of sheath boxer
briefs they're stretchy fabric is made
of moisture wicking technology makes
them super soft keeps everything cool
comfortable right in place all right
sheath is particularly useful for
staying cool it's hot out here in the
valley man so I depend on Chief to keep
my junk dry all right dry like a
freaking bearded dragon man I love the
Dual pouches that keep your band Parts
separated it's a game changer you don't
want them all bunched up sticking to
each other like a tag team sheath uses
materials like bamboo mesh for even more
cooling comfort you guys are going to
love them they are the very very best
they have bamboo shirts and shirts and
hoodies as well all right it's all
designed for maximum comfort and they're
you look dope too all right go to
sheathunderwear.com that's
[Music]
s-h-e-a-t-h-underwear.com and use the
promo code shop receive 20 off today
that's sheathunderwear.com today use
promo code sehaub for 20 off let's get
back to the program thank you
Chief sheath they are nice
alrighty
um I thought this was hilarious but I
don't know did you and chale talk about
this what he talked about Ian Gary's
thoughts on Izzy versus Strickland no
okay so here's
here's what he said about Ian Gary
because Ian Gary said that if they were
to fight again Izzy and Strickland Izzy
would take it and then after he said
that Chael made this video which is
super funny these are chills words not
mine you know I'm a big game Gary fan he
put don't make fun of people with
special needs but I would say I swear
that person doesn't have special needs
or I remind you not to say things like
and it starts with a r to describe
somebody's stupidity
that was insane that was done by Ian
Garrett I couldn't believe it was it a
drunk Ian Gary I don't think so he
looked perfectly sober
Gary
to jail going for them views I love this
Uncle Jeff uh I get it bro
um but so chailed just because Ian Gary
said Strickland would win in a rematch
no no uh uh Ian said that Izzy would win
his rematch but then chael's saying like
no he dude Strickland dominated the
entire he did dominated yeah yeah but to
just assume stricklands do that twice in
a row is okay to that means open yeah
yeah but it was just funny how hard to
jail
if your way of proving this silly and
ridiculous statement that you just put
out where you got cliches from all over
the fighting World none of which you
create on your own if your way of
proving that to be true is a rematch
them again and get a different outcome
then you can sit back and say see I told
you well not really that's called a
prediction predictions come from guys
hanging around the water cooler you're a
fighter give an analysis and a breakdown
I'm a fighter who gives an analysis of
breakdowns I don't have the foggiest
idea what you just said geez man yeah he
went hard on him
it's not crazy it's not even that big of
a reach to make I think it was different
if they fight again okay
but he it was a one for jails but to
Jail's defense like no no it was a
five-month shutout dude
but who knows what Izzy was dealing with
we still don't know hopefully comes on
says something and maybe Strickland
Styles just on this street first yeah
all right so since the merger happened
with the WWE and UFC uh the president of
the the WWE said that now the UFC
fighters that have personalities and
stuff they have an Avenue to go to in
WWE
you know to prolong their careers
I love this well I mean certain ones do
that have yeah personalities that are
big stars they're not just going to take
like an undercard kid who gets cut and
put them in the WWE the other thing is
is if they're retiring you know like
Amanda Nunes or you'll hear Fighters
talk about their bodies getting broken
down and they just can't do it anymore
oh and you think the WWE is the answer
you're not bad their bodies might get
taught I think it's fair to say their
bodies get more tore up than a UFC
fighter they're on the road 300 days a
year you're jumping off ropes you slam
in the face with steal chairs and crap
you know so okay I think it's a good
thing to say I think a few of them a few
outliers are going to get there Kobe
Covington could do it
um
that's it
W like you gotta have a personality man
like they've had world-class wrestlers
world-class wrestlers that come from the
Olympics
and they put them in the WWE program
they have no personality and they go
we're good
I mean you have to have a personality
Sean Strickland Sean O'Malley I think
they do well agree
yeah Derek this would be great too yeah
watch it
I won't come through would he be that
Paul Bear guy be like yes
Islam's like what the hell is going on
here
yeah that's it's not my point my point
is there's not a ton yeah so to say like
this WWE merger is good because these
guys have a career after yeah maybe five
of them will and it's very hard on their
bodies yeah or you could just oh my god
dude I have a crazy idea or he could
so they don't have to destroy their
bodies in WWE
there's that yeah that's insane though
that's stupid
don't come after me for saying that jail
alrighty uh you mentioned Colby
Covington so it's been up in the air as
far as Leon Edwards versus Colby comes
in it's always like we're not sure it's
happening or not but uh I think yeah
Edwards manager said that it's going to
happen either at 295 or 296 this year
that division was popping now it's just
a screeching halt like Brian Cowan on a
podcast just
the division was popping and then just
the way the UFC's gone about things and
then you got our boy belil Mohammed
waiting you just let's go man yeah do
something hey 170 do something
somebody do something yeah I fight each
other that's what we do for work fight
each other
it's insane it's stupid that division is
getting lost in the dust dude everybody
else moving forward
all right let's go here real quick uh
this is a quick one from pfl so Kayla
Harrison she's been out for a while
she'll be going back to the pfl and
fighting
Julia Budd I think a rematch on November
24th
just thought I'd throw that out there
guys her not coming to the UFC was a big
mistake and it's in hindsights she lost
so now it's off it's easier to say but
it's just like yeah she's hiding yeah
um and this one's the word a little
controversial one so Ali Abdel Aziz put
this statement out this also relates to
Kayla Harrison he says all these cheated
basically saying all these women that
cheated in the pfl because now the pfl
has adopted the usada program yeah
so Dumber yeah so he's saying that
everyone that fought Kayla was on you
know stuff or whatever and then
obviously
Chris cyborg
uh we'll start was thinking that she's
talking about or thinking that he was
talking about her but he didn't call
anybody out particularly no but he goes
they were she's never fought
no no she never had she never fought
Kayla yeah so Chris cyber is like how
dare you because he goes everyone has to
give urine uh urine and blood samples
and they will start to look like females
again and not males so I guess she took
that you know like a like as a thing on
her whenever someone's that that's the
problem though when someone's that
insecure about something there's usually
some truth to it you know
um and I'm not saying that about cyber
arms we never know yeah it's weird that
she would come out and attack him just
stay silent all right whatever he put
this is Ali's words not mine uh they'll
start start to look like females again
not males I don't know who you are
talking about but if I'm the one coming
from Bellator I hope you have the same
energy when I see you in person I will
not tolerate sexual harassment that's
Chris cyborg talking about oh
interesting yeah so she's like I hope
you have that same energy in person
yikes and she's yeah she's a badass yeah
yeah you don't want her you know not
your case
you saw it as no fun man so many pfl
people can pop left and right though
yeah
yep even in slide fighting
I mean that's just silly they they
actually test and slap funny yeah so
this is a little bit older but this is
something that happened where Al
Jermaine Sterling put something on his
phone saying rematch sugar right yeah
and then hello I know but I'm saying we
didn't I don't think we covered this no
293 and then Cheeto says I'm next and
then marab says what your turn number
six that's funny yeah
um
I thought this was pretty cool Jorge
mazura the New York City catwalk he's a
model dog whatever yeah damn without the
shirt too
those people are so serious in the front
row and that chick she's cool yeah she's
super cool I'll show you her Instagram
in a second
but uh yeah damn might as well just
doing the damn thing he's looking Dope
fight League owner model to keep
everything
crushing it and this is that girl she's
like smoking hot oh never mind what is
what is is she uh she Brazilian or
something
um
I'm not sure she from Heaven Hernandez
sounds like she's oh no she's like
Mexican yeah
but uh yeah she's smoking hot yeah she's
cool what else you got chin um we should
probably do some more reads oh hell yeah
dude uh like I told you guys if you're
gonna use DraftKings or use any betting
um Outlet I'm telling you don't listen
to me I'm biased as hell so I'm I'm
proud to announce I partnered up with
fancy Guru you're talking about experts
they give you preview of NFL games your
fancy football straight up UFC picks for
the big big fights even the fight nights
they work hand in hand with DraftKings
who you make a more informed pick for
your shot at one million uh dollars top
prize every Sunday on DraftKings all
right and the experts they help me out
to give me picks so I can give you guys
the picks these are experts it's not me
and Drake giving picks all right just go
to fancyguru.com that's fancyguru.com
musiccode shop schab for 20 off that's
fancyguru.com use the code shop for 20
off to get expert picks so you can make
more money with DraftKings wherever
you're betting your fantasy football UFC
college football listen to The Experts
don't listen my dumbass that's
fancyguru.com promo code shop 20 off to
get expert picks invest in your picks go
to fancy Guru
all right
one more
this episode of the shop show live is
also brought to you by happy hippo
they're doing all sorts of giveaways
they're doing discounts it's the best
Kratom on the freaking planet only
Kratom that I trust they're the first
ever to Market K dips all right they got
the Wintergreen there that I use all the
time they have the Razzle Dazzle fruity
flavor they have to create them energy
which I use non-stop they have the
highly concentrated just straight up
extract uh Kratom shots they are the
best of the best when it comes to Kratom
whatever you want to get your Kratom
into your brain whether it's pills
gummies powders k-dips shots we got you
covered it's the One-Stop shop
happyhippo.com promo code is thick23
that's thick with three C's
t-h-i-c-c-c 23 you get 20 off for Life
share it with your family friends Uber
driver Postmates I don't care who it is
all y'all can get 20 off for life all
you gotta do is go to happyhippo.com
promo code thick23 hit it Jen relaxed
okay so I didn't know this but Derek
Brunson was recently released yeah out
of nowhere yeah out of nowhere and his
record's not too bad like he just lost
2-0 against Jerry cannonier and Draco
suplesi's which you know he was on a
straight up run before that
yeah they just released somebody but I'm
curious and I saw Ali put out a
statement it seems like the UFC is doing
a thing kind of what they did with Nate
Diaz like go wreck the ball Brothers
oh okay we're gonna release you and your
mission is to beat Jake Paul okay so
that's what he's wanting to do to fight
Jake Paul yeah I think UFC's like go do
your thing go beat Jake Paul we're gonna
release you beat Jake Paul and then you
come back
because they're not gonna entertain like
yeah he's still UFC fighter we're gonna
let him fight Jake Paul because that
opens up the floodgates nope we release
you go beat him quit the hype there and
then come back that's what I think
happens otherwise it makes no sense he
lost two of the very best lose to drink
is it's not you know not the end of the
world yeah 11 years in the UFC yep
I I think they're just releasing the
hounds and they want to take out the
Paul Brothers
by any means necessary not the easiest
fight for dick Bronson not exactly known
for uh his boxing
yeah all I'm the memories I have Derek
Brunson is him just like going crazy
yeah the UFC might be
in a little bit of trouble there if they
they think Derek Brunson is the guy for
the job not saying he can't do it at
least he's not like some he's not like
he's long on the tooth and super old and
he's a dog he could do it but I I don't
know if that's the guy to get it done
I don't have a favorite over Jake Paul
do you no not for boxing no definitely
not
all right you want to do some fan
questions sure man all right this is
from Metal Sonic uh Brendan what is your
dream lineup for UFC 300
what would it be if you could if you
could pick it
Ronda Rousey Pena
Jon Jones Francis
hamzat Strickland
damn
you like that don't you do
um
Bo nickel uh drikis
shot O'Malley Cheeto
toss Patty pimlin on there against
whoever
um
volkanovski gaichi
any other brain Busters nice that's a
fire ass lineup
nah I don't need those distractions
Casey with the Connor
um let's see I don't know if you covered
this already but let me see so Jason
Ellsworth asks Brennan what he thinks
about the Broncos almost winning they
finally looked good they looked all
right they but also remember they threw
a a Hail Mary at the last second and
didn't get a two-point conversion they
are who we thought they are they're the
same team from last year but better
coaching
it's clearly a Personnel problem we have
great coaching champagne's one of the
very best to do it
it just we paid too much money for uh
Russell Wilson we don't have we can't
use any of the other cap space to bring
on any tools form which is not very good
it is what it is
neither are the Chargers the whole that
the FC West is due to Chargers I mean
the the Chiefs they're all right
they're still you know really good but
all right Chargers owned two Raiders
ain't crap Broncos ain't crap it's a
bummer
oh Super Ball pick I mean right now
they've played two crappy teams Dallas
looks good
um Miami looks good
Niners
not as who I picked this year I like the
alrighty all right the last question is
from Mark W
um how do you handle those hard nights
on the road in hotels I work on the road
and I miss my family for months at a
time and I need some advice brother I'm
with you man I don't have any advice if
if the meaning it's good you miss your
family that means you're a good dad the
guys that can just go on the road 24 7
and just you know ditch the fam like oh
it's a good getaway I'm just I struggle
with myself I'm doing less tour dates I
actually just had a meeting uh last week
with my team I'm gonna start doing less
tour dates I'm actually helping my son
in baseball coaching as well I can't
miss them you're not going to get those
back you're just not get now it's
different if you have to be on the road
to feed your fit like you have to do it
in order to it sounds like it send your
kids to school yeah it's a different
animal brother then you're you're it's
different where you're showing your kids
you know a work ethic is what you have
to do in order to provide that's
different and I I get it brother that's
horrible I don't have any advice on how
to deal with you know not missing the
family it's a good thing you miss the
family I really struggle with it it's
getting worse it's getting worse so I'm
down to make less money and not touring
so much and to be home I love being home
I can't miss my kids baseball can't miss
his football I I have to be around you
just have to you're not going to get
these years back so that means making
less money and not you know having as
much fun on the road I can accept that
good but good luck brother Godspeed
you want to end on Bryce Mitchell yeah
let's do this because since he's going
to be fighting this weekend yeah so you
have a fight night on Saturday uh Great
Main Event great co-main event uh even
Marina Rodriguez and uh Michelle
Waterson is a good one too Brian battle
uh Ricardo Ramos
um Tim Means not a bad uh Mohammed
usman's always fun to watch Jay color
gonna get a knockout there not a bad
fight night not as good as the past
weekends but I bet we get some funner
fights but uh physive gamra's a mother
trucker great fight
great fight
people sleep on camera for whatever
reason yeah so and that's when I was
real high on Darius because the weight
Darius was able to handle the grappling
of gamra and you got to realize gamron
is a 80cc Champions can grapple his dick
off people don't realize that so expect
to see a lot of that with the physique
fight we'll see how physiv bounced back
after that Justin gate you lost
but what we're gonna say about Bryce
Mitchell he's fighting Dan Eagle which
is a great fight yeah definitely great
Bryce Mitchell then you guys a fun fight
Rodriguez watterson's a fun one
some fun fights that main card's good
great I mean for fight night that make
cards great so Bryce Mitchell recently
posted on his Instagram uh something
about his
hold on I just had it right what the
hell
no it's no no no you had it no no it's
Instagram it's uh you drinking this
morning nah dude all right just checking
oh you are yeah
um so Bryce Mr posted about his
ex-girlfriend going to his property and
destroying his fruit trees and he's also
worried about him or the girl like
attacking his girlfriend quick question
girlfriend quick question yeah how does
uh his ex get on his property and cut
down several trees without somebody
being notified he lives in the country
is that a quick thing it's a country
like is it like out there and you can't
see she's like
[Music]
ha I don't know I'll let him this is so
country because most girls just key your
car or whatever yeah just I'm gonna cut
down your fruit trees and he all right
he was like working on those trees for
years and years he's planted them
there's Babies we're talking about
avocados here limes fruit trees oranges
tangerines let me let him explain here
sorry oh that's why
my carrot tree
now my ex-girlfriend runs a tattoo shop
on Booth Street and for the love of God
if you're not evil and you're not a
coward don't give her your business
the tattoo shop on Booth Street the
woman that runs that came by my place
and destroyed all my fruit trees
I've been working on those trees for
years and she came by last night and
killed them all
he's so hurt because
this [__] is evil yeah man and I'm
begging the the community of Cersei to
help me guys I'm out of town and my
animals and my wife is at home by
herself I please I need my neighbors to
help I need my neighbors to help this
evil woman is going to come by she's
threatened to kill my dogs she's
threatened to kill me she's threatened
to kill my all my animals and I'm
telling you last night she came over and
killed my trees now that my trees are
gone she's going to try to kill me she's
going to try to kill the dogs or she
going to try to kill Aaron for the love
of God can the people in Cersei please
damn me
and she runs a tattoo shop on Booth
Street and that's really all is it the
only one on boot street I'm telling you
I don't want to laugh but yeah I feel
like it's a small town so it's probably
it's probably the only tattoo shop in
town so The Whole Town's like we know
that one that sucks dude he's out of
town his girls that does suck yeah that
does suck but the thing is why is she
still mad at him he's married kids and
he's on a farm oh he has a new
girlfriend but I don't know what
happened with them oh he said she didn't
kill my girl yeah I don't know how long
ago it was it's a little bit of extreme
to jump from he killed my she killed my
fruit tree she's gonna kill me and my
dogs
uh but he probably knows something more
about the she sounds batshit crazy she
does Oh you mean the female tattoo
artists don't have her
it doesn't mean
you can be a tattoo artist and be cool
but I mean this person this particular
person seems like not the best yeah it's
yeah hopefully hey neighbors help them
out yeah he's busy getting ready to
fight Dan ige which isn't an easy test
she shouldn't be worried about his fruit
trees help him out neighbors I love
Bryce
yeah but that's a that's the Bryce
Mitchell story there since he's fighting
this weekend yep so he's the co-main
event on the fight night Saturday
physive gam Rock great one like I said
Marina Rodriguez Michelle Waterson we
got Brian battle AJ Fletcher Ricardo
Ramos
um Tim Means the phone miles Johns
Muhammad Usman it's a fun Fight Night
there's gonna be some bangers on this
um and I will be watching it from my
Green Room in Spokane Washington one of
my favorite clubs Love Spokane right
outside
um
oh what's that place called in uh
Coeur d'Alene it's about 30 minutes
outside Coeur Lane I freaking love Coeur
d'Alene Coraline gets mad when you bring
him up like keep it a secret that
Secret's out for God's sakes Kardashians
ruin it for you not me uh but I'm spoken
watching this weekend Thursday Friday
Saturday Spokane Washington next week
I'm in Vegas at skank Fest 29th and 30th
then I'm in Iowa in October Niagara
Falls in November Chicago December
um that's it for right now but spoken
Comedy Club come on out kids Thursday
Friday Saturday this week come say hi if
you have dope trucks please bring them
so I can look at them and drool over
them that's Spokane Washington this
Thursday Friday Saturday Spokane Comedy
Club thanks for watching love you guys
be nice each other like subscribe do all
the things the kids tell you to do until
next time I'm out